in the last video on the Drake Equation
we tried out some numbers we just made
some assumptions it seemed reasonable at
least to me and we got that there should
be 12.5 detectable civilizations in the
Milky Way galaxy and I talked about a
bunch of reasons about why we aren't
detecting them but I left out one of the
most obvious reasons that were not
detecting them and it was rightfully
pointed out in the comments below that
video and that's just the signal might
be too weak if there's 12.5 if there's
on the order of you know 10 11 12
detectable civilizations in our galaxy
they could be quite far from us this
isn't the Milky Way but this is a galaxy
that probably doesn't look too different
from our Milky Way we could obviously
never get this vantage point of our
galaxy unlike at least not for a while
not unless we can travel quite far away
from it but let's say that we are over
here you could imagine if there's if the
10 civilizations or the 12 civilizations
are here 1 2 3 4 there's probably a lot
more in the center actually so because
that's where our density is higher so
let me put it here 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10
11 12 the closest of them might be tens
of thousands of light-years away from us
and there might be a lot of stuff in
between all sorts of crazy things
happening stars exploding all sorts of
signals that we're receiving and it
might just be that the signals from
those civilizations are too weak to
reach us or that there's they're somehow
too much interference from all of the
other craziness that's happening around
the galaxy there's also these other
reasons that I talked about in the last
video maybe they've they've gone beyond
using radio as a form of communication
and that's why or you know they never
use it to begin with and that's why we
don't even see them ever using it or
they use it for a very short period a
kind of a transition period and maybe in
a hundred years we'll discover the next
best thing the other the other idea
behind why we're probably or maybe why
we might not be able to detect
civilizations is that well there might
be a lot fewer than 10 I when I did the
Drake Equation right over here I just
made a bunch of assumptions
these seemed crazy but I assumed I kind
of assumed a reality where you didn't
have these kind of cataclysmic events in
the galaxy on a regular honor at regular
intervals but we know that there are
cataclysmic events that happen in our
galaxy in other galaxies the one that we
know the most about although there
probably all sorts of things that we
don't know much about our gamma-ray
bursts and these are still kind of
trying to be understood gamma-ray bursts
and you could watch the video on quasars
those are those are essentially a lot of
a I guess highly energetic rays being
released when all of this material is
being kind of absorbed into supermassive
black holes at the Centers of galaxies
that are tend to be very very very often
billions of light years away and gamma
rays are one of the things that get
emitted from those but you can also have
gamma-ray bursts within galaxies we
believe maybe certain types of stars
when they collapse into black holes you
have this burst of gamma rays there
might be certain types of neutron stars
with the right properties that might
every now and then release gamma rays
and the view is is that if there is a
civilization that is within a few
thousand light years of it near one of
these gamma-ray bursts and it's in the
wrong place it's kind of in the path of
the bursts then it's a good chance that
those civilizations will be completely
wiped out that those planets will be
sterilized because there's so much
radiation coming out from that gamma
rain there's even some theories that
some of the extinction events that have
happened in Earth's history so now we're
talking about the dinosaurs we're
talking about billions of years ago
maybe a billion years ago or two billion
years ago that these might have been
caused by relatively local gamma-ray
bursts the theory is is that these might
hit earth on the order of once every
billion years and if you think about the
galaxy as a whole we're kind of in you
know where our solar system is orbiting
the galaxies it's kind of a nice
distance from the center of the galaxy
the closer you get into the center the
higher densities of stars you have so
you can imagine if
if earth gets hit with one of these
gamma ray bursts every couple of
thousand years you can imagine something
closer to the center of the galaxy gets
hit with these gamma ray bursts much
much much more frequently just because
there's more activity there there's more
stars that are closer by more stars that
are aging more stars that might be
collapsing into black holes so the
simple answer is we don't know there
could be a thousand civilizations out
there we're just not sophisticated
enough to notice them just yet or there
might be very very few because of all of
this craziness that happens in in the
galaxies or them you know who knows
there might be none although I find that
kind of that's not too exciting so I try
not to think about that one